hey guys Ryan right here hey Dan Seibert
here so the trailer for Halo 5 two
trailers just got released no way Ryan
yes wait Daniel yes this one is halo 5
guardians the Master Chief ad this was
the first one i was sent to us let's see
what all the hype is about
hi oh hi I'm am I on the hype train
we'll find out soon right here on the
real rejects the [ __ ] you next time
on the real rejects
and at least she is this live-action is
this what you wanted is this what you
were looking for was everything you've
counted eyes everything you've done was
it
this
Wow Foom is complete
this just beginning the [ __ ] prepare for
the hunt with Xbox one in the Master
Chief collection now 349 I want that I
do want that too I didn't know it was
gonna be live action that look beautiful
what the [ __ ] why is that not a movie
yet it was they've been working on it
good deck actually I heard that they're
releasing this around the time there's a
show that's billboards producing it's
gonna be on like Showtime I think and
it's a Halo series yeah yeah so that's a
[ __ ] bad that's pretty badass
yeah what the hell is happening in this
game now
I thought you played as Locke I don't
know I thought that's why I thought like
Master Chief went missing yeah well
Master Chief like he goes missing and
then there's this new guy but apparently
the Master Chief's about to put a bullet
in his brain yeah he's like dude your
time is up is like Master Chief gone
evil eye dan you should have the answers
I don't because I haven't played the
game that's why it's over it's only a
trailer it's only a trailer why waste
your guys's time and not to mention
money let's just throw in the other
trailer right now good time a minute
yeah because it costs time is more
valuable than money fact you can always
get more money get more time
to the awesomeness just continues
the conquering hero let us remember him
as a detective
give us this as our Savior and now our
betrayer let us see you together as you
and not the one who's supposed to save
us all but the save us what the hell is
going on right now is it like is it like
two different timelines or something
like universes they're dealing with you
okay well I mean this implies a couple
of things that there's gonna be multiple
endings yeah you're either gonna play as
Master Chief
or as Locke oh so it's not you're
definitely playing as Locke you might be
able to choose one who might be playing
like two different storylines oh cool
that would be smart because not
everyone's gonna be on board with
letting go Master Chief yeah this is
just kind of the like direction that
like gaming is going is that more and
more games have like your choices
actually make a impact yeah in this
story now this is gonna be like Mass
Effect level Joey's making probably not
a tail up we're there for multiplayer
well they never spoke about that how
they like no I don't know as hey are
they the people of Halo known to be like
kind of it's very linear okay it's very
linear so it's very strange to see this
or they just really want to confuse the
hell out of us all that you've done it
they gave us very similar scenes with
the character switched and [ __ ] is hope
yeah and it's st. hunt the truth so
maybe there's a conspiracy going on I
don't know it gets you thinking though
and the fact that it's live action it
looks really good really good it looks
really good
well here's the thing it's like every
trailer for Halo 5 up until this point
has also seemed pretty like basic it
looks like Master Chief's gone you play
as walk go find Master Chief we need
them to save the universe
and then this [ __ ] comes out and it's
like who's the bad guy bad guy who's the
biggie you know you're saying bad gay
right oh you're not saying bad guy I'm
saying bad guy you're saying bad gay do
you not hear yourself binky you're
saying bad Yankee Yui Yui anyway guys
thanks for pounding my butthole telling
me that trailer was out if you knew the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects so dan has a gaming channel
plays games on there sometimes it is
underwear who knows Dan does and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter social networks we're trying to
get more followers because the life is
lonely as youtubers cuz our worth is
determined by a number on a page exactly
giggle gamer that's his name
hey I am 15 year old who plays video
games with face cam I thought that said
face cut nope you're 15 I upload every
day and I would really like to get
noticed on YouTube what's not too hard
there's billions of people on YouTube I
would really like it if you could give
you a shout out to get me started thanks
everyone
subscribe to giggle gamer alright
we're taking a photo of you to really
show the world that there's the photo
that's giggle Jaber he's like so chipper
the best way to represent karo gamer is
this stoic faces he's like data fart put
that up please no dad no it's going to
this last thing you're 15 so as always I
have to give you advice on becoming an
adult oh good I got to keep it
age-appropriate wait for this Dan no
this is going to be very sincere go for
it one day you're going to hear the word
orgy orgies are not healthy terrible
things can happen in orgies I'm talking
horrible diseases that will just cause
your genitals to fall off multiple
pregnancies
this is the horrible situation I'm
trying to warn the youth about orgies
dan not didn't start putting your money
in a savings account you need it for
college work hard do your homework on
time that's all [ __ ] of living life
like the average person I could tell
Google gamers gonna get Eddie down a
road connection